le Déméter a fêté de Roumanie vers
Londres
transport de biens privés
contenu des caisses inconnus
au large nulle terre en vue
[Musique]
comme université de Cambridge mais je
suis bon maintenant la traiteur accepte
de verser une prime si nous arrivons
promptement à Londres
[Musique]
du coup ça veut dire rien à signaler
un excellent navire ça ne fait aucun
doute
les bêtes ont été déchiquetés
elles sont toutes mortes on dirait une
morsure
[Musique]
un mal terrible
la nuit il boit notre sang il
nous l'appelons
DRAC
vous avez vu la taille de ce monstre
[Musique]
je vais tuer cette créature maudite
il est à bord
aucun de nos morts
le diable existe
que Dieu ait pitié de nous